on this episode no legend stops by
this is
ask Gary B how do I do the intro again
everybody is Gary Vaynerchuk I just did
one library TV which I have a different
obviously no is this what is this mozi
boat 184 so I'll call 185 I'm just gonna
make up whatever comes out my everybody
this is gary vay-ner-chuk and this is
episode 184 5 or supposed to be 4 we're
going with 185 we're gonna skip 184 Seth
look this I know you like we like to
call you the Guru this is the real guru
185 of the ask Gary Vee show and I am
fired up I know what I push against guru
too I am fired up I kid about having you
here I'm in a real India's here the
whole crews here Stefan but who's really
here is really one of the true pioneers
of the modern marketing movement
somebody that I've gotten to know over
the last half decade and it's been a
real pleasure because you get to know
Pino I've enjoyed the relationships that
I've gotten from the other side people
that are coming up the game they've got
to know me we're friends I feel very
very honored for you to be here on the
show set please please tell the one
person in the vaynernation
who's watching this right now who
doesn't know who you are a little 47
second bio or whatever you like to roll
how would you like to say hello I
noticed things for a living and try to
point them out to people I'm a teacher
I've started a couple companies more
than a couple I do projects and I try to
make a ruckus that's a good day that is
a good day and it's been a good life
that way I'm not complaining it's been a
thrill and a privilege said how many
books have you written
well there's 18 bestsellers when I was
like an official author then so ready
for that might pop up might come on for
is Barry Nolan do you wanna put on you
18 I wasn't looking I'm gonna make I'm
gonna go for 19 you know that right
is that a Tiger Woods Jack Nicklaus leg
is it 18 it's 18 I swear my god I was
over a teacher I know your hackage er I
did a book a month for 10 years so
they're those other books but then
there's 18 so it's a little bit just
because I think it's been quite
enjoyable for the
audience I know that for a fact a little
bit deeper like a little bit you sold a
company yeah like a little nothin don't
you here for a little minute um why
don't you start out cuz I don't know the
stuff I would say the big turning point
was helping to invent commercial email
as we know it that's not spam that when
I started doing it in 1991 most people
did not have an email address that's
right and persuading backers that we
were going to invent a way that email
could be used think about any email you
got today that you wanted to get that
came from a company not a person that
that didn't exist before we did it
and so Yoyodyne was a business that we
built to do that before that I was
booked back to before that I worked at a
educational computer game company we
invented pretty much commercial
educational computer games like kids on
keys infraction fever and I had a line
of science fiction games it was a great
fun I was 24 it was so lucky that I got
that job that was pretty cool of the UH
of the 14 bestsellers that you've read
1818 see I'm trying I'm trying
attracting already getting four is that
a subliminal that means that I can forge
a new worry fee book yeah we don't need
to talk about that
I hear it's called a scary didn't as you
can pre-order it on signup I'm gonna
have to make volume two three four five
six seven eight nine and I watch sugar
by fortune coffee and it's not body
that's tomorrow uh set of those books
you know do you have a favorite I know
it's like children do you have one that
stood out I mean I know that Purple Cow
seems to be like every time I talk to
people about you like out what I think
of you that seems to come out of
people's mouths quite a bit tribes were
somewhere I got mentioned in which was
very big for me so thank you at the time
I was starting the wine thing any of
them stand out was there anything that
real most authors will tell you that
their favorite book is the one that did
itself that's what I say Thank You
economy that's so weird I wrote a book
called survival is not enough Charles
Darwin wrote the foreword Wow and India
is laughing it's true you can look it up
google it right now and it came out
right after 9/11 which was not a good
time to say the whole world is going to
be
we should like that it took me over a
year it had 45 pages of footnotes didn't
fit in that I published online it's as
close as I'm ever going to get to sort
of a scholarly thing and most people
shouldn't read it because it's not what
matches the Gestalt of what we're trying
to do today yeah but I have a soft spot
in my heart because no one bought it
right yeah the new book what to do when
it's your turn I designed every page I
wrote every page it made me happy to
sort of play with the medium yes right
yes and but they're all my friends my
books I look at I keep them on the
shelves so that I can look up so I
remember when I was the person who could
write that book interesting I don't
think I could write most of my books
today and where do you sit today in book
writing in your mind this was a year and
a half ago there hasn't been one word
since then it's just not on the agenda
it's not something that people are ready
to buy another book maybe from you but
not for me the word our attention span
is different our priorities are
different so I'm focusing on the school
I run the Alton ba I'm focusing on how
do I craft each blog post as if it was
my last one how do I want to get
interact with gay people India I
apologize said India I know you have the
questions is there one asking him about
his social media versus I saw that
comfort did you pick that I knew you
he's really good like that don't leave
it for that so okay we're gonna get some
questions okay cuz that's where the
cameras you know we just talk cameras
are on high the cameras are on d-roc is
doing Facebook live ID rock the rock out
what's going on with Facebook live how
many peeps are we having
I'm sure 14 now there's Brad three point
three 3300 viewers
very nice parting the decimal 2000 makes
it sound like a much bigger than it
sounds much bigger three point three
without point three people are watching
it big shout out to the third of the
person India let's get into the first
question
Dimitri good Russian name good start
Dimitri asks what is the value of
authority in a world where everybody is
a possible thought leader doing that
Pete the question uh no you don't have
to think about it not nope you can that
gets picked up semantics semantics
matter a whole
cheer what does Authority even mean and
I think the currencies of anybody who
wants to make change happen right now
our attention and Trust and they're in a
virtuous cycle you don't get attention
unless you're trusted you don't get
trusted unless you get attention there
are other kinds of attention you can you
know let yourself on fire in the street
you don't earn trust doing that so this
attention trust cycle goes around the
question then is how do you get there I
don't think you get there by saying how
do I hustle a content media play to
figure out how to get in front of people
who never heard of me and somehow seduce
them I think you do it by being generous
I think that people tend to trust folks
who step up before they have to they
trust people who keep their promises
especially when it's not convenient they
trust people who tell them the truth and
if you do those things they are probably
going to tell someone else and you'll
get more attention and more chances to
be generous and the cyclone goes it goes
goes and guess what it probably never
ends at a moment where you say okay now
it's my turn to take take take
we left the take-take-take part out
mostly you don't feel like you own Heinz
Oh Heinz anything you don't feel like
you owe TWA anything you just are in
this environment where you know your
attention is precious you know your
trust has been abused if someone shows
up and treat your attention with
kindness and earns your trust every day
well then one of the byproducts will be
they'll want to hear what you have to
say next
super easy to figure out why this guy
and I get along if you've been watching
this show because that just wrapped up
184 episodes in one statement I think 83
I know I think I'm trying to play along
here I think what is super interesting
about that answer and this question is
that's right and I think it's and I
think one of the reasons that I've had
personal success is because I think
about things in such a long period of
time that that answer spoke to me
because it's my natural state when you
think about things in a 10 or 20 or 40
year kind of cycle well then your
behavior matches that and so you're not
worried about that one week one day one
month even one year
volts and then I also think the market
gets to decide there's one thing that I
very much I just put a little asterisk
please because you're about to sell
yourself short here please there's a
glacial strategy which says I'm a
glacier I'm going to make it all the way
down the Hudson to the ocean and it's
obvious where I'm going I'm just going
to take a long time yes I would say that
the strategy you're talking about which
you have done consistently is that at
any given moment the short-term thinker
thinks you're an idiot because you are
not trading and that's the key is that
you are doing things that are so
generous and so trust earning that
people look at you and say why aren't
you doing that other taking thing and
it's that feeling that the people around
you think you've lost your mind
that's what makes it scary I'm a mom I'm
a little I'm a little bit weird and you
know this because of my purpose because
my personality actually on stage and
style makes people think I am in
short-term game you know I'm I recognize
that my vibe at times comes across as
the worst version of the things that
you're referring to and so it takes
people a little bit of time to
completely figure me out as a matter of
fact I would tell you one of the
interesting things about how I live my
life is the reason I so deeply you know
feel infection towards you is I was
surprised myself how quickly you like I
can I judge people based on how quickly
they get me or not
and and it's and it's and I always
wonder if it it's I'm never sure if I do
it on purpose
if the shtick is almost weirdly on
purpose or was it always naturally I
think it's naturally there based on what
happened in school long before I thought
about these things but that's right and
so I think at the end of the day the
thing that really really matters to me
is whether Seth says it whether I say it
whether the president says the bottom
line is the market gets to decide you
know when you make book when you write a
blog post when I feel like I mean you
know at the end of a the market is the
judge and so when you think about who's
the taste maker who's the authority in
today's world we clearly have mediums
today I mean look what's going on here
right now
you know you thought about this that's
fine but
basically I mean it's incredible doom
live and production TV here think about
this 20 years ago you've been through
the whole gig and everyone owns their
own media company it's quite one thing
we need to amplify here though there
isn't one market there are many markets
yes okay so you can sell to a market
that wants you to be a pickup artist
hustler whatever but just please
understand that's your market don't call
me because I'm not your market and my
argument is that most people especially
the people you want to be trusted by
don't like to be hustled 100% and I wish
that a whole bunch of people call
themselves growth hackers in quantum
rubber I would write on the wall most
people I care about
don't want to be hustled because being
hustled makes you feel bad
agreed what else you got India right
Bryce Brown next name he's got a canyon
named after it does Bryce s where do you
see the internet going in the next five
or ten years and why so that you know
what's the next big thing my argument is
this is the next big thing that if you
are waiting for something beyond a
billion people connected online with
mobile being the driving force with a
fight for attention and with constant
froth around the edges if you're waiting
for something else you're going to miss
out on a big chunk of opportunity this
is our revolution there was the
Industrial Revolution there was the mass
media revolution there's this and it
will keep changing its flavor the names
of the public companies that run things
are going to have to change but their
own layer on top of the sillies don't
wait for the next thing this has been
the next thing since 1991 and the people
who asked me you know at the newspaper
conference in 93 when I told them what
was coming said well we'll just wait for
that it know this is our this is it what
we got I totally agree with that and I
the one thing that's on the horizon that
I think a lot of people are paying
attention to is VR and I say to a lot of
people I'm like look that's a ten years
away this in 1998 I thought by the year
2000 everybody would come into my wine
shop and know the price of everything
and so I think the thing I've learn
and my version of that a same exact
answer is there's a long way away before
if VR is truly you know contact lenses
sitting at our home being in places
we're talking about 15 to 25 years away
from the scale we're just hitting the
maturity let's not forget 15 to 17% of
all e-commerce done in America is done
online nothing if you told me in 1998
that only 15% of all things bought would
be online by the year 2016 I would have
set there as a [ __ ] do I even want to do
this that's forever from now this stuff
doesn't go as fast as we all think it's
going to 30 years ago today yes 1986
sitting in my office in 215 first
reading literally today we're like I not
making that part about 30 years ago for
second city Marvin Cambridge
Massachusetts you know who walks in I'm
26 years old who guy named Guy Kawasaki
yes
now you apples the greatest well I was
already a beta tester and we did a deal
with him right the point is if guy had
waited for the next big thing he
wouldn't have become Guy Kawasaki I had
waited for the next big thing I wouldn't
have become me and you wouldn't have
become you this idea that there's always
the froth around the edges there are
people who are working in VR today who
are going to go off into something
interesting but it's not going to be
because they're right about VR it's
going to be because they're right about
being a trusted person worthy of our
attention that's the arc of the people
you trust and the brand's you trust not
that they got the product right the
first day or the iteration right the
first day it's that they made a
commitment to show up in a certain way
in a certain universe in front of
certain what's crazy about that is when
I think about the thought leaders in
marketing and names that people throw
out there and authors in this space 30
years ago he walks into your office it's
unbelievable that when you have the
chops hey how long you can keep the
attention of the end consumer be how
long this all plays out like I just got
fired up the level of domination that
I'm gonna have in 2037 just dawned on me
and I'm really excited about 2037 you
should be except football will be
against the law in it don't even sorry
let's go
Rene asks what will cause you to hire
the world's best psychic even the
Caesars and Pharaoh's consulted a seer
and so should you grades well she
already knows the answer I feels great
go ahead you go no that's the thing with
psychics they already know why are they
asking next yeah I mean look I you know
you guys know where I sit on this one I
won't meditate I don't need to see
psychics all up it's not okay to put
those two things in the same set yes it
is also not well you don't get the same
I do cuz one is science yes and the
other one is not okay and we can't
science is one of the coolest things
that's ever happened to mankind it's not
science it's not okay I'm telling you
the truth about this I mean I don't you
know he doesn't you don't like it but
you can't deny I don't get it where I
sigh right so it's not okay to start
conflating things that are based on
science versus things that are not
correct okay thank you so let me ask you
a question what do you think about
emotional intelligence seriously like
like can I tell you something can I can
I tell you something that weirds me out
go ahead
help me here because I trust you why is
it that often not always and I
understand brain tricks and all that
[ __ ] but I'd get weirded out when I
think of random [ __ ] like somebody I
haven't talked to in seven years and the
next day they call me or like a million
other things like tell me about well
that was [ __ ] wait that is nothing to do
with emotional intelligence most
intelligence is Daniel Goleman's
semantics take on what we need from
people the ability to look people in the
eye the ability to not eat the
marshmallow the ability that emotional
touch is an important concept that
people should understand you're talking
about instinct intuition s okay let's
have conversation can they not be
innocence can't they be they're not
related things no there's not I believe
you you're probably right think about
the people you know who you've hired
here right yes the ones you like the
best aren't the ones who are better at
typing than someone else or they're the
ones who have the emotional intelligence
to bring tension to bear to cause change
to happen in a way that benefits others
there's nothing to do with a friend
calling you know no question that okay
so coincidence is super easy to explain
please we as humans are storytelling
machines yes we notice things but we
have to make stories about yes you
yesterday thought of more than 300
different people probably more than that
and one of them called you right you
paid attention to the coincidence yes
but you didn't say holy smokes
two hundred ninety-nine people didn't
call me today that's right the reason
the coincidence works is as story
manufacturing humans we're always
looking for that correlation and that's
why people buy lottery tickets because
they think that there's some sort of
weird cosmic numerology thing going on
because we're wired to look for weird
coincidences but there aren't actually
weird coincidences in the world because
I think there are I didn't say that
that's what you said no there's plenty
of things that aren't science because we
make up stories that are irrational what
I'm saying is there's a good reason we
evolved to make up stories that are
irrational yes because they kept us
alive because sometimes there's a
correlation between the stick breaking
in the lion jumping out of the woods and
then when we listen for sticks breaking
it might keep us alive and we'll have
grandchildren and other people will
listen for sticks breaking where it
breaks down is now there are no lions
but we're still listening for sticks
breaking we're looking for broken
windows we're paranoid about certain
things because those and sharks hippos
and sharks sure I love that look it up
if you didn't understand that
go ahead India Jonathan asks Seth has a
blog but no other social media
engagement under which conditions is
this advisable I think it's advisable
under several conditions condition
number one where you want how wouldn't
you saw your blog really it was 89 as an
email newsletter yep so through the math
you know it's a long time ago then I met
Joey Ito and switched it to type pad you
know was some blogging before that but I
can't find it I don't know where it is
yep and then after I met Joey Ito I've
been doing it as relentless it's like
there was a period it was 5 blog posts a
day and then I realized it wasn't
helping me or the reader so now it's
been one a day
for a lot more really long time do you
know how long years and years so the if
you want to develop to get through the
dip to be the best at something you're
going to have to say no to a lot of
things you love no no is super important
super important and so when Twitter came
along I said I could be pretty good at
this because I'm early but I would have
to use my blogging time to be pretty
good at this so better which time do you
spend on a blog post you think on
average I mean I'm sure they go very
well I spend 10 hours a day thinking
about the next blog post I write a bunch
but you don't see most of them what do
you just like kill them yeah no Leslie
stick around right you might back you
might like I assume when you're spending
10 hours a day in 4 weeks you may spend
10 hours you're like oh [ __ ] and recover
out that's that's it
that's why I think every human should
have a blog even if you don't put your
name on it everyday write something that
you're willing to put in the world so
that a week from now in a month from now
in a year from now you can look back at
and say I said this I predicted this I
keep a journal as a youngster no not at
all
do you like writing and I like and I
like what talking about ideas I like
helping change happen there was a time
in the middle of the 18 books when the
thought of sitting down and going to
this practice of writing a book really
engaged me but it's I'd rather look
someone in the eye and talk to them
then what about public speaking we've
gotten to do a couple of minutes love
giving talks I hate flying there I love
being on stage you're on and then you're
off you have it there rules you can't
bring on you know a chimpanzee a
marching band you can you're allowed
your slides I have rules right you can
use this flies we can't go beyond that
can't throw things into the audience and
stuff I like that but but that's too
many variables so back to India's
question yes what was that oh yes let me
so Steve Pressfield in this book the war
of art talks about the resistance in
lynchpin I talked about the lizard quat
yeah I do
eery books yeah like how many books in a
year will you read well I get two or
three a day in the mail
I read them until I get the joke and
then I stopped so that's a thousand
Jesus but sometimes you don't need to
read that many Pig ask for garyvee
dimension that's on sale and you can
pre-order it now on Amazon that book
will probably take me more than 15
minutes to get the joke because it's
just rich and layered and a lifetime ago
of insight you know what I'm saying yeah
but there are other books like if the
author did a good job in five pages you
get the point you trust that the rest of
it is proven and now you can go on to
the next thing it's cool I'm not good
what's the last critic computer for you
you enjoy recently well fiction wise
there was there's a book a
whiskey-tango-foxtrot hysterical
brilliant funny science fiction and it's
about you you're in it
yes well you know when you're not gonna
like the Devereaux character is that Who
I am
yeah is he handsome yes yeah but that's
not the best thing to say about him
that's only care of parts of it that I'm
in anyway and then there's there's a
really great book about a novel about
marcel duchamp's work called the bride
who was stripped bare by her bachelors
even that's the title yeah that's a
really juicy book Oh India's fired up
there you go and then but nonfiction
wise I'm just constantly amazed at how
generous authors are because authors
know you can't make a living writing
books but they do it anyway
anyway we're still answering India's
question I'm running out of time on 70s
it's Jonathan Jonathan wait so the punch
line is this the punch line is were
[ __ ] Seth Godin you don't have to do
it because you're a beast in 20 years
Wow completely the opposite of course
Zig used to say you can be a meaningful
specific or a logic said when you're in
Seth Godin right away with it has anyone
ever walked out on the show yes cuz I
could go second I have something
important to add here go your heckling
I'm sure I am I just you know what I'm
just having my own he was my friend I'm
sure I bought that's good
so Zig used to say you can be a
meaningful specific or a wandering
generality interesting and the problem
with most social media is you are not
the customer you are the product it was
optimized to make you anxious until you
use it
again was optimized to extract from you
nervous energy not productive output so
most people who fall into it are
checking one less time checking this
posting that liking this why to keep
them from doing important work which I
was watching television for no not fee
but wait let's let well a TV yeah but
hold on here's where we're gonna
disagree a little bit I mean like like
little stick here for a second India a
lot this thought that all of a sudden
MySpace and Friendster and Facebook and
Twitter came along and took us away from
all this mass important work you know so
let's start with Clay Shirky Clay Shirky
pointed out that Wikipedia got built
mm-hmm on a decrease in television
viewing that that billion hours yet were
invested on building Wikipedia came from
TV it could have come from reading no he
can he shows it his great book it came
from TV he put a chip in everybody's
head who look listen I can't talk about
this though what do you do you know if
there's me with me well I'm not a great
but you can't deny this scholars work
without examining it and say wait nice
challenge that let's we'll have $2.00 no
no I think that's fair and I think
you're right about that I do no question
do I believe an enormous amount of
internet behavior has come at them at
the at the behest of television so what
my point is television is dying because
we're giving people more choices because
the channels are breaking down etcetera
mass is going away what do we want
people to do with the time they're not
spending watching happy days they're
still watching a lot of TV which is
stunning to me
I agree to that but my argument is the
people who are watching you and I talk
right Bryce and Jonathan and the psychic
who already knows what I'm about to say
yeah they set that up have the ability
to make a dent in the universe 100% we
gave them a platform they can use to do
100% and they think that they're
advancing their cause by using various
social media networks the way that they
optimized to be used and my argument is
they're not that I am super glad that
the musicians of the 60s that went way
out on an edge weren't seduced by just
sitting there listening to Beach Boys
records all day they decided to make
[ __ ] brewer they decided to make slow
train coming or whatever it is they went
outside the thing to say this is my work
and the problem I have with the people
who are just saying me to plus plus they
think they're doing their job they're
not doing their job they're hiding from
their job their job is to create a body
of work that earns them trust that
attention click you know that that's
interesting but let's let's go a little
bit deeper here because this is sort of
I like this don't you believe when
you're saying plus plus and this is on
the other thing don't you believe that
that is exactly mapping the people that
in just like not everybody is going to
make great bodies of work not true okay
go ahead you think they're born that way
no the people everyone who makes great
work was born naked yes unable to read
yes and pooping in their diapers okay
right somewhere along the way you make a
decision you make an investment you go
forward okay and if we look we see that
it used to be that John Hammond would
pick you and you would become a famous
recording artist yes I mean you know I
believe so the Pickers are gods and so
now the number of people who are picking
themselves keeps going up what all I'm
saying my only point in this case is
this if you find that at the end of the
day you could say I did a really good
job and my social media universe is
clean and taken care of and that's all
you have to point to today I don't think
that's a good day and what I'm saying is
Sally pants McGee who has that 2.2 in
1974 had that same thing to point to him
better oh she has a chance to do better
so what you're saying is that everybody
can go to Yankee Stadium today hit the
bat on table and take a swing which is
different no no give me up yes yes it's
athletic endeavors are different
athletic endeavors are different than
intellectual endeavors for sure
hold on so when you're saying is
everybody has the same capacity to learn
no what I'm saying is what we define as
athletic endeavors is one axis but I
could say for example if you're a
caregiver for a senior citizen who's
struggling with Alzheimer's yes you are
capable of looking that person in the
eye yes with empathy and affection in a
way that changes them tell me how you
develop empathy tell me
well now you're changing the topic we do
have that time because no no because you
just said I can teach Andy how to be a
caregiver that's gonna Andy can
definitely be talking on let me finish
let me finish lost cause Andy Andy Andy
you can teach to look in the eye chatter
teacher grant I can teach Andy yes
deduced I can't ever teach him to hit a
home run and Yankee Stadium okay I can
teach him to do something with his voice
is hard enough so with Yankee statement
a lot you can't teach him to hit a home
run in Yankee same but you can teach him
to be the best version of a baseball
player that he can be in the same way
that you guys know economic utility well
that's a whole different conversation
but that's the guy who says I'm trying
to have what you keep interrupting no no
not true not true
because what's most interesting to me is
there's no economic situation that Sally
pence McGee could be focusing her time
on something else besides liking buttons
on Grace's data meow we disagree okay
well hold on hold on sure do you agree
with me that Sayle pants McGee would
probably likely in 1984 to be sitting
and watching well that's what I'm saying
right I'm saying nothing's changed the
places that people are deploying their
energy my point is that liking something
in Instagram or Facebook is a way to
hide from the productive things she
could be exposing herself because the
productive thing is scary
you think you think you think she's
she's gotten to a place where that makes
her feel better
and that we've tricked people and people
tricked themselves to be a part of
something versus when they sat on the
couch no when they sat on the couch the
entire culture was in on it and it's
similar what I'm saying is we didn't
build the internet so that YouTube
cat videos we built the internet but
isn't our cat that eases videos escapism
for somebody just like a reading a good
book as escapism for you
seriously I'm asking I know people
around the world who have something they
really need to escape from okay the
people who are watching this much less
fine I would argue and agree with you
that people have much bigger headaches
than but the reality is that somebody
who's watching this has their micro
version of what they think they're
escaping from I sit here every day and
go yell and say look if you're a white
male in America Jesus Christ she wants
about winning the lottery you won so I'm
with you on that what what I'm
fascinated not entertaining there's
nothing wrong with it
people think cats just technology just
acknowledge you're entertaining yourself
you're not doing your job that's fine
that's the only thing I'm trying to say
so the fine with their question but the
question to India was yes what I'm doing
my from India was when I'm doing my job
why aren't I using the other forms of
social media the answer is well you'll
find what your job or your said Neil
Gaiman has said is the way he deals with
writer's block he hasn't written a book
and needs to do is he makes himself
super bored he eliminates all inputs and
so until he's so bored the only way to
entertain himself is to write so are you
saying that one of the big KPIs for you
of just staying to the blog was not
getting all that stimulus and allowing
you to create more forcing me to say
either I did nothing today or I made
something worthwhile that there are days
when I will answer nothing but email
yeah and I feel horrible at the end of
the day because I don't believe that's a
productive meeting part of this last
four or five minutes was for me
Seth's self-awareness for himself and I
think that to me is the most interesting
part of what just happened like to me
that speaks to really understanding
yourself and positioning yourself in the
best position to succeed based on what
and all the successful contributors /
artists I know are similar so for me
I'm Nydia like I just walked here I just
walked into my office though I laughs it
was so quiet I started yelling and
everybody that I can't get into my place
without all the impress that awareness
is key it is but if we look at
most of the people who are showing up in
my box in your box you're saying what do
I do know what ideas they're copying
pattern yes in social media without
being aware of the factual media though
well I missed the question without being
aware that those patterns are sabotaging
there the question was for you when a
winner when is it right when is it right
for that I think that's amazing what I'm
saying is first try nothing see what
happens if you are forced to level up
not by fitting in but to level up by
standing out by saying something
important you know Janice you need funny
I'm just sitting here I'm thinking it's
one of the funniest things about how I
go about things is I don't want to read
anybody else's things I don't consume
anything else because it puts me in that
but really not even like I'm crazy that
way like I don't want to consume
anything because I just like observing
people in whatever format the real world
or the digital world to be able to just
do my thing because that's what makes me
comfortable in analyzing it's a little
bit of like a it's interesting so the
way so the way we built the auto MBA
which is a school area yes is it's 28
days and there's an enormous amount to
do yes with your name on it in public
yes and commenting substantially with
your name on it on other people's work
cycle repeats I can repeat 1314
assignments in four we do some people
struggle with that system everyone does
that's what it's for
yep right if you if you if I send you to
Ranger School yep you're going to
struggle if I send you to tightrope
circus school you're going to struggle
that the learning is hard that's why the
dropout rate on online course is at 98%
is that true yes and the reason is
because as soon as it gets hard and it
has to if you're gonna learn something
you quit well that's what people are mad
at watching my content because I talk
about hard work and they don't want to
hear that they want to see what the
secret is exactly I need you know what's
funny about that India I'm looking very
fit thank you brother because that's
what India's referring to I need to be
accountable to somebody I figured out my
trigger in that game I needed to be
accountable somebody else besides myself
exactly India last one John asks what is
something you both disagree on Linux I
mean I think I think that everything
self-evident but
mostly it he is a superstitious
troglodyte who wants to deny that
science expect it and I had Charles
Darwin right before one of my vote I
believe in science tremendously I
believe believes a you to more than I
believe in it the thing is gravity
doesn't care whether you agree it's not
just a good idea it's just law science
is just like the market it is what it is
I mean I'm super fine with science
I don't understand it I don't know what
it is but I'm super cool with it
listen Seth I'm super pumped here on the
show man it's a pleasure how can people
find you online they know how to find me
how can i what I want to do is let's
link up make sure everybody starts
reading sets blog on a daily basis it is
massively very much knowing my audience
this you know for the few of you that
don't do it it will be a tremendous
addition up to you throw send me email
send him email do not send me right
because I just like people a lot more
than set that's true it's just true it
is that's what we disagree on i like
human beings set doesn't accept you get
to ask the question of the day any
question will be a lot of answers will
get some consumer insights from it which
I love who would miss you if you were
gone mmm-hmm he's a deep soul that
thanks for being on the show thank you
love you have you guys are awesome all
of you you keep asking questions we'll
keep debating
you